un mois maintenant du premier tour des
départementales la voie est libre ouvre
le débat et passe en revue les quatre
départements de la région première étape
aujourd'hui est avait lieu dans la
nièvre lilian melet et ses invités ont
fait une pause le temps de cette édition
on les retrouve tout de suite en direct
dans le studio juste à côté merci
emmanuel effectivement deuxième partie
de la voie libre spécial élections
départementales dans la nièvre avec
patrice joly le président du conseil
général pascal de mauraige pour le
groupe d'opposition de droite françois
diot parti communiste marcel stéphan
pour le front national et gilles marini
pour les candidatures nièvre à venir et
justement ces candidatures nièvre à
venir c'est une spécificité de la nièvre
on se souvient des élections municipales
denis thuriau s'est présenté il s'est
ensuite alliée avec l'ump lui dei pour
prendre la mairie
ce qui nous amène à une vraie question
sur ces élections que nous voulions
poser oui tout à fait est ce que comme
pour les municipales avec nevers à venir
votre allié naturel et la droite vous en
parliez tout à l'heure en désignant la
gauche un petit peu comme votre
adversaire
je crois savoir qu'il ya eu des
discussions avec la droite avec la
gauche vous monsieur joly il n'y a pas
des discussions parce que sa démission
entre
notre parti on nous n'est pas question
de faire des alliances pour l'instant
nous a dit qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
discussion un matériau a encore dit ce
matin dans les colonnes du journal du
centre qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
discussion savez bien que tout le monde
se croise en tout cas il n'y a pas de
conflit il n'y a pas de consignes ou
d'alliance
nous sommes nous avons une vocation
sommes différents les autres ne sommes
pas un parti nous sommes un
rassemblement de gens d'intelligence de
différentes orientations de droite de
gauche
moi je mets conviction toute la droite
bat binôme s'est concrètement si vous
remportez des cantons est ce que vous
savez d'ores et déjà dans quelle
majorité potentielle vous dit pas tout
nous nous n'avons principe de me
défendre des valeurs des valeurs de
respect de tolérance
quoi qu'il advienne nous défendrons au
moment venu
le candidat qui portera le mieux à
l'heure pas très joli on a vu ce qui
s'est passé à nevers est ce que vous
considérez que les listes tenir à venir
sont pour vous dans l'autre camp
aujourd'hui assez clairement moi je n'ai
pas eu de nouvelles discussions avec les
représentants de contrairement denis va
revenir à votre amant à ce qui vient
d'être dit donc et le positionnement ce
que l'on entend les échanges et
discussions effectivement qui sont sur
la place publique montrent effectivement
il ya une alliance au moins tacite voilà
avec le groupe actuel d'opposition du
conseil général nous face à 6 mais c'est
très bien aussi et au moins les choses
sont très claires
alors ce que je veux dire simplement
c'est que quoi qu'il en soit si
d'aventuré j'étais à nouveau président
du conseil général avec une majorité
autour de moi il nous nous reviendrait
de travailler comme nous le faisons
depuis maintenant quelques mois de
travailler avec l'agglomération de
nevers la ville de nevers en toute
intelligence parce que nous sommes deux
collectivités importante pour l'avenir
du département de la nièvre
agglomération sur son ami habitant la
ville quarante mille conseiller général
200 à 1000 nous ne pouvons rien faire
d'autre que de travailler ensemble sur
des objectifs communs pour l'avenir de
ce département avec monsieur jack et à
votre droite ans et vous partez sur un
seul canton ensemble c'est à vos ailes
et je la question c'est pour mathieu duo
est ce que c'est symbolique aussi
sachant qu'il y aura
très prochainement des élections
municipales peut-être même le jour des
comptes des départementales nous pour
notre part nous ne sommes jamais dans
des accords ni de sommet ni d'appareil
mais ses réserves d'or de contenu et si
effectivement il ya un accord à
varennes-vauzelles c'est d'une part
parce que nous avons à faire à
varennes-vauzelles à nous c'est le
canton où nous avons un conseiller
général sortant le seul canton
d'ailleurs la proportionnelle il y en
aurait 5
bon c'est qu'on a affaire à
varennes-vauzelles à des socialistes qui
sont en rupture avec les orientations
gouvernementales actuelles d'austérité
et de la réforme territoriale donc nous
travaillons sur un grand rassemblement
avec des écologistes dès que des gens de
sensibilité communiste sur le socialiste
était à contre l'austérité contre la
réforme territoriale est effectivement
il ya une élection municipale qui va se
dérouler bientôt puisque la droite qui a
été élu a été convaincu de manoeuvre
électorale donc le conseil d'état vient
d'annuler l'élection et dans cette
élection là effectivement il ya une
opportunité de regagner tous ensemble
dans notre diversité à gauche avec mon
ami olivier sicot de redonner à
varennes-vauzelles une ville de gauche
je comprends soignons paraît que vous
vous êtes croisé donc ne verse
clairement il ya des cantons où il n'ya
pas de gens de chez vous il ya des gens
de chez eux et vice et versa donc on
doit y voir un accord pré pré pré
panneaux je crois qu'il ne faut rien y
voir ce que l'on peut partager c'est un
certain nombre de constats constat
d'échec par rapport à l'actuelle
majorité du conseil général
donc on peut se retrouver sur un certain
nombre de choses mais pour l'instant
rien n'est fait voyons au soir du
premier tour
marcel stéphan le regard vous portez là
dessus parce que la critique des
politiques c'est aussi votre sujet donc
ils sont un peu sur vos terres bien sûr
mais bon nous on est là on y va à visage
découvert à ces élections au front
national rassemblement bleu marine
on les alliances on n'a pas ce souci
savoir avec qui on va faire alliance
après effectivement marine le pen l'a
encore rappelé l'ump est si on en a eu
la preuve encore partiels du doubs
ou juppé appelle à voter socialiste donc
tout est clair pour nous on sera seul au
second tour mais bon à visage découvert
front national voilà y'a pas merci
messieurs sur sept petits chapitres
politique court parce que nous avons
passé beaucoup de temps sur la partie
programme au dépôt au départ messieurs
dames pardon parce qu'il ne me reste que
si on n'a pas le temps car l'histoire it
et non plus tout à fait et vous avez
raison c'est peut-être les partis
politiques qui ne doivent s'en prendre
qu'à eux mêmes et pas forcément les
médias dans ce cadre là si je peux me
permettre
tout de même on en est au moment des
conclusions pour chacun une conclusion
de 45 secondes dans un ordre que nous
avons tirée au sort préalablement en
commençant par vous marcel stéphan pour
cette conclusion ben moi est ce que je
ferai dans cette conclusion je
n'appellerai pas les gens à voter pour
moi bien sûr j'espérais surtout s'ils
veulent sortir de leurs problèmes à nos
ports revoter pour les gens qui les ont
créés voilà donc c'est clair je souhaite
un bon dimanche
et puis rendez vous le 22 mars c'est
très court françois diot dans chacun des
17 cantons il y aura un choix positif
un choix authentiquement de gauche le
choix du rassemblement anti-austérité
avec les candidats du front de gauche
sont 68 candidats dans chacun des 17
cantons qui ne sont ni des notables
locaux ni des candidats de bidons c'est
des candidats qui tous habitent ou
travaillent dans leur canton et n'a pas
un seul qui est parachuté c'est des
candidats du monde du travail des
syndicalistes des militants associatifs
des élus des responsables culturels qui
sont à l'image de la population
nivernaise ça va de l'ingénieur à
l'intérimaire ça va du demandeur
d'emploi de crue la ville aux médecins
de l'hôpital de château chinon donc des
gens sincères pour qui sont pour moitié
qui ne sont pas membres d'un parti
politique mais qui ont des convictions
et qui eux les assume en se cachant pas
derrière le sans étiquette ou nés ou
derrière des slogans fumeux nièvre ceci
n'est vrai seul voilà bref
mesdames et messieurs qui nous écoutent
et des gens comme vous qui incarne
l'avenir de la gauche toute entière
c'est-à-dire l'humain d'abord
merci françois diot patrice joly a
conclu justamond par rapport à ce qu'il
ya d'être dit
sur mon canton celui sur lequel va être
candidat à château-chinon nièvre à venir
est composé de membres anciens ou
actuels de l'ump les choses sont un peu
dit ça illustre les choses étaient
d'ailleurs une question qui a été posée
sur ce que je veux ce que je veux dire
aujourd'hui surtout en matière de
conclusion s'est invité nos concitoyens
à participer
l'avenir de ce département va se jouer
aussi d'une certaine manière les 22 et
25 mars prochains
venez participer c'est la manière dont
chacun peut participer à la communauté
départementale à laquelle nous
appartenons tous les événements du mois
de janvier de du début du mois de
janvier nous montrent que la démocratie
la république les valeurs elle s'use que
si l'on ne les utilisent pas il nous
faut donc être acteur de notre vie
d'autres à venir et donc j'invite à la
participation citoyenne la plus
nombreuse possible parce que celle qui
aura le plus de sens j'invite bien
évidemment à vivre peu à voter pour les
candidats de vivre la nièvre composé de
membres du parti socialiste mais composé
également de personnes qui partagent nos
valeurs de gauche qui se retrouvent sur
un projet sur une dynamique est engagée
au cours de ces quatre dernières années
et donc qu'ils veulent poursuivre le
combat pour la défense et la
construction de l'avenir de la nièvre
merci patrice joly pascal de mauraige à
vous de conques et bien un naufrage
démographique échec d'attractivité
destructions d'emploi et de chômage des
jeunes échec économique pauvreté
désespoir des nivernais échec social
je vous le répète un sur vingt est ce
qu'on peut avoir des bonnes raisons pour
continuer à voter pour les personnes qui
nous ont amené à cette triste note après
50 ans du parti socialiste dans la
nièvre et au vu des résultats que chacun
connaît et peut malheureusement apprécié
la nièvre a besoin d'un nouveau souffle
souffle de la confiance retrouvée
souffle de l'efficacité souffle d'une
solidarité équitable souffle de la
créativité dans tous les domaines nous
savons bien sûr que ce sera un travail
difficile
il nécessitera du coeur et des
compétences
tous les candidats de l'année
evre s'engage ne manquent pas ils
méritent votre confiance électeurs ni
mère du nivernais vous aimez la nièvre
venez nous rejoindre et ensemble avec
nos candidats dans la nièvre s'engage
refusons la fatalité et relevant le défi
merci parce qu'elle demeurait jean
maurice et vous acquittez rage au sort
de la dernière conclusion le 22 mars les
électeurs de la nièvre août un rendez
vous majeur
moi je leur donne rendez vous avec le
mouvement tenir à venir ensemble nous
pouvons exprimer un message fort de
renouvellement avait des candidats qui
n'ont jamais été élus au concert au sein
du conseil général ne va venir
c'est le pari de la différence du
rassemblement la programme partagé c'est
moins deux des buts de démagogie moins
d'idéologie plus de pragmatisme pour
plus de résultats
c'est le pouvoir de rassembler des
intelligences diverses
au delà des appartenances c'est la
richesse de notre mouvement c'est notre
ambition
on veut être aussi un antidote au vote
extrême
enfin pour finir nous ne sommes pas un
parti mais nous avons au moins le parti
pris de défendre la nièvre et ses
habitants merci je ne m'en ait ni c'est
la fin de ce premier débat départemental
merci messieurs dames une garantie à
tous les actes de prévenus de battre
merci jean philippe
merci vian on va suivre ces élections
dans le journal du centre bien sûr à
fait et puis sur france 3 avec un
journal des élections qui va durer trois
semaines à partir du 3 mars tous les
soirs avec des gros plans sur tous les
cantons important de la bourgogne samedi
prochain sur ce même plateau un autre
débat sur ces élections départementales
on vous parlera de l'yonne ensuite dans
l'ordre ce sera la côte-d'or et enfin
pour terminer la saône et loire
donc rendez-vous même heure même endroit
ici le samedi prochain en attendant
merci à tous les cinq d'être venu de la
nièvre
ici dans nos studios dijon bon week-end
au revoir
on
oh
pourquoi